but more people trust the IRS than they
did Facebook with protecting their
privacy
i'm paul dietrich with reason TV and
today we're talking with recent
foundation polling director emily Eakins
there's a new reason drupe poll out
today that deals in part with NSA
surveillance thanks for joining us Emily
thanks for having me with the revelation
in The Guardian The Washington Post's
and other publications about the NSA
looking after people's internet data
their phone call records what did you
find so we asked them to choose if they
saw the program primarily as a means to
fight terrorism or primarily a violation
of privacy and a majority of Americans
said it was a violation of privacy so
while most Americans do you agree that
it's a violation of privacy independents
are the most likely group to say it's a
violation of privacy particularly
independents who lean Republican and
this is something we often find in our
polls that a lot of libertarians are
found in the group that identifies is as
independent but they lean Republican do
you think libertarians are going to be
upset with that kind of distinction
perhaps but to that point a lot of civil
libertarians are also found in the
independent group but they lean left
now our Americans up in arms about all
of this not exactly we asked Americans
if they thought the NSA surveillance
program had impacted their trust in
government only a third said that it had
decreased their trust in government
whereas a majority said it really made
no difference either way you also asked
about Edward Snowden people keep asking
if he's a traitor or a patriot what did
you find
Americans are split about a third say
he's a patriot a third say he's a
traitor and the rest don't really have
an opinion partisans are more likely to
say he's a traitor and independents are
more likely to say that he is a patriot
young people in particular were twice as
likely as older Americans to say that
he's a patriot you found something
interesting when you looked at a
Facebook and the Internal Revenue
Service the IRS well we were interested
in what and who Americans trusted more
in protecting their privacy Facebook the
IRS Google the NSA and what we found
might surprise you
now most people don't trust any of those
groups in protecting their privacy but
more people trust the eye
ress than they did Facebook with
protecting their privacy but we have all
these things associated with the IRS
that they get into politics that they
they use their power to go after
citizens they still trust IRS over
Facebook
well to be clear about two-thirds don't
trust the IRS with their privacy
it's just that three-fourths don't trust
Facebook and it probably has something
to do with the fact that people upload
pictures personal information to
Facebook and so they invest a lot of
trust in Facebook protecting their
privacy the Obama administration has
said that they only use the NSA data to
fight terrorism to go after terrorists
but there's a chance that it could be
shared with other government departments
other government entities are people
afraid of this at first glance Americans
oppose the NSA sharing the secret data
it collects on millions of Americans for
anything other than combating terrorism
however we asked about a few particular
circumstances and we found that
attitudes changed now first about
two-thirds of Americans say that the NSA
should not share secret data with the
IRS but they would favor sharing it with
law enforcement agencies looking for a
missing child we also asked about
whether the NSA should be allowed to
share its data with the Drug Enforcement
Administration in that situation
Americans were split right down the
middle with younger people more likely
to say it should not share it with the
DEA and older people saying that it
should so what we learned from this is
that while Americans don't want the data
to be used for things other than you
know combating terrorism when you give
them particular circumstances especially
those that are more emotionally charged
then attitudes change and they're more
open to sharing the data
the reason root pool covers a lot of
different topics what else did you ask
about in this poll we also asked
Americans about what they think about
government spending the debt ceiling the
implementation of the new health care
law the Detroit bankruptcy among others
the full poll results will be available
at recent calm forward slash Paul thank
you very much Emily Eakins thanks for
having me for recent TV i'm paul
dietrich
you